good evening ladies and gentlemen and
thank you for coming along my day job is
public policy editor of The Economist
but like you tonight I'm here to listen
and learn from a very fascinating debate
I'm sure you'll agree natural gas
revolution hot air or a dose of sanity
possibly a bit of both the timing could
not be better I think we know that when
we've seen the Prime Minister drag back
to explain his declarations on energy
that we know that we're in the right
ballpark in terms of a subject that is I
think coming up the political agenda
very fast indeed and gas is at the
center of this in so many ways is it the
energy source of the future it's
relatively clean it has low emissions
compared to coal so we would of course
be doing our bit for the planet if we
list in the direction of the age of gas
there's plenty of it around in the
ground meaning that a reasonable portion
of our energy at least would be
generated from secure sources and that's
in a world of slings and arrows of often
unstable times it would of course be
very reassuring but others would argue
to the contrary it is a short-term fix
the price of gas does seem set to rise
it is already risen quite steeply and
it's different in different parts of the
world and in different political
jurisdictions and what about climate
change if we're serious about that
should we not be putting our attention
elsewhere and developing the UK's vast
potential for wind wave and solar power
so there are powerful arguments on all
sides of this debate unfortunately we
have some powerfully argumentative
people here to put them to us and of
course lots of time for engagement and
questions as well we will get underway
now I will just tell you briefly how it
will work for parts geology and
availability of gases our first topic
will then move on to the environment
then to the geopolitical situation and
security questions that arise from that
and we will finish with a conversation
on the impacts of this developments on
UK policy followed again by some
questions so if your favourite bit
hasn't come yet it is coming down the
line very shortly but first of all I
would like to introduce our first
speaker tonight that's VIN Thomas who is
chief energy advisor at shell and head
of the energy analysis team at Shell's
global scenario film is going to speak
for 10 minutes BIM please take the chair
quite a challenge to do it in 10 minutes
so let me but you were the goodtime keep
it there so that section so actually let
me just welcome all and then go straight
away to my Keefe slides and that is the
key messages and then our other slides
afterwards are really the bonuses just
let me say a few the key messages I mean
all the people think that you still have
to wait for new breaks with technology
and I don't think that's the case we
have the existing technologies but they
have to break through and that doesn't
come by itself and uncle venture gas in
America was a big surprise to everyone
say in the last decade but the first
pioneers were already out there trying
to develop the technology in the 80s so
it takes a few decades about three
decades for new technology to really
come through and that's a very normal
time span in the energy in this industry
to actually have new technologies coming
on stream to about 1 percent market
share when it actually becomes
competitive with existing incumbents so
bear the mind three decades before it
becomes competitive another three
decades before it actually reaches a
notch at natural market share so it's a
really internet intergenerational game
then the other aspect is something about
efficiency a lot of policy is based on
efficiency that we won't improve side
ekr something built in around 15% of the
next 25 years
but efficiency doesn't come by itself it
has his own dilemmas policy dilemmas
because you know who's going to pay for
it because if an end consumers not to
have the expectation that end consumer
price will continuously rise
why would invest now up front a lot of
money to invest in efficiency
well governments normally like to say
that energy should be more affordable
cheaper every day
and here's kind of India kata me to the
breach another critical technology which
we have to really come to grips with
soon is carbon capture and sequestration
CCS read to be calm and asked a power
system I'm afraid if you want a lower
carbon system you can't do without a
technological fix called carbon capture
and sequestration then my second key
point is actually that gas will be a
backbone of sustainable energy systems
of the future why do I say that well
guess it's abundant and affordable etc
but if you want to have more and more
renewables intermittent renewables in
your system you need a kind of backbone
and flexible backup source which can
actually take up the flexibility very
cost efficiently now we have done a lot
of scenario exercises and every time
right you see that actually gas is a
very good cost-effective way to actually
deal with it in the mitten sea but also
we see some kind of natural saturation
points in certain sectors of renewables
so when people say hundred percent
renewables for everything is possible I
doubt it and certainly not in the next
20 years so gas will be really important
in the future and then I think the third
main point is actually that it's urgent
policy action required people think they
have time because 2050 is long way 80%
then reduction seems to be still doable
but there's a kind of momentum you have
to build up now and we see actually a
lack of policy development certainly in
a meaningful co2 price because that's
the best way of actually steering
consumers behavior and doing more energy
efficient things or actually pay for new
low carbon technologies like CCS and
also something what is quite often
forgotten is market structures here a
lot of debate about electricity market
and you know we want to have mandated
renewables in because it's too costly to
the free market way so you get that and
then he said oh you have intermittency
how to solve that all we need capacity
payments for generators to have capacity
standby that's great so the generators
get a kind of non market-based
compensations you could argue but that
really pushed
the flexibility requirement down the
supply chains to the volume providers
the guest for find us in this case of
call providers cause easier for heap and
you ever built carrier but guess comes
long distances in gas pipelines of her
LNG's and when there is no security of
demand because you have no clue how much
you going to sell what a price is going
to be why should Russia develop a field
ten thousand kilometers away from us
well he doesn't have a long-term
contract to finance it and that there's
another security and supply element so I
would say is yes you need market reform
but also the commercial aspects of
market reform needs to be taken much
more in consideration and integrated way
between electricity and gas etc and
incumbents and then my last point is
release that key uncertainties are there
and I meant intervention gas is a very
good example right will it really be
replicable elsewhere in the world it's
the success of North America is that
going to happen in China and South
America and maybe in more modest form
here that's not very certain look at the
policy debate as a public debate about
fracking people don't really sure right
and why should we do that
but if unconventional gas is successful
it really doubles the previous thought
resource base of gas and then it really
makes it a real game change you can
really go for different type of energy
systems in a sense that you can early
gains replace coal by gas but as you
build an big infrastructure system on
gas also you start opening up options
for the future I will call it say you
have room to maneuver in 2020 2030s
because you haven't gas infrastructure
which is also easily as little extra
cost
they make suitable for hydrogen gas or
liquid hydrogen
so actually Macau you're lucky because
you have an infrastructure you can
piggyback on if you do in other routes
then you don't have the infrastructure
and then it becomes very expensive to
introduce hydrogen why do I mention
hydrogen because renewables yes it's a
good idea to decarbonize but it needs
storage it needs some way of exploring
these electrons in your useful form and
also it needs a medium
actually be useful in other sectors than
electricity like sensors transportation
so maybe in 10 year 20 years time when
the hydrogen technology has really
evolved very cost-effectively and you
have liquid hearted carb liquid hydrogen
you can transport in tankers it really
become complementary of such gas system
and it gives you much more flexibility
in the future there are a few key
uncertainties as well and not yesterday
China most people think ball China's far
away what does do with us our gas
position well China's decision on policy
on the energy mix is very determining
how much gas will be available in the
rest of the world if China feels
comfortable say 4 times or five times
their present gas consumption by 2030
then the market will be as big as the e
use market as today and 600d cm is a lot
of gas coming from the market yes they
will have some domestic supply but more
so more the more their own uncle venture
gas becomes successful in you in China
the more infrastructure they're going to
build so the more guest penetration you
have in China so the more comfortable
they are to import a lot of gas via ng
and guess what who competes against that
it's the EU for for most and I'm almost
finished and the last point I want to
make is acceptability really we talked
about all those negative new
technologies but it's very much new
technologies are hard to have accepted
by the public if it's uncle venture gas
is the fracking debate if its carbon
captures their storages yes great but
not under my my house although people
are very happy with producing gas under
the house for many years but they're not
sure about this YouTube position so
social acceptability is a real issue
which you have to deal with and as a
shell right we are more and more now
convinced that we have to engage
communities for instance very upfront to
to be for it to make it an acceptable
and maybe I should stop here then if you
what to be in time that would be very
noble of you thank you thank you very
much have a natural agitation of a radio
presenter I think every 30 seconds is a
crime against humanity but it just
allows us to have a bit more discussion
later but we're going to have a brief
discussion now about some of the
subjects they're arising from that very
interesting presentation do we have some
questions anybody like to get us going
with questions and could you of course
please identify yourself when you ask
your question good evening my name is
Chameli Bhatia and I'm from Paris France
as humanity and from my accent I've
known women for a number of years and
happy just to make a first comment which
is very good
I think summary of what is known and
what is also unknown and I think that at
least two points with which are alien
known the first one is I would say Gav
sorry the availability of carbon capture
and sequestration and you put it clearly
but I just want to insist another point
which seems to me very important is
whether or not shale gas will appear in
other regions of the world I know that
shell as bad owners as shale gas in
China but I think in China's are
enormous problem there are problem of
access problem of water there are
problem of Jirachi because the shale gas
- very nice pointed questions are under
one view of your own so if you mind I
would just like to take an answer - yes
so let me pick up the point of how
certain is this uncle venture gas
revolutions elsewhere in the world and
of American wealth America seems to be
on the roads but still people have to
realize that the success are able to
call sweet spots geological sweet spots
or is a big area but if by random
drilling over all these 30 years they
found certain areas where actually it is
really profitable to do it but
unconventionals are not so prolific as
normally as well so you have to drill an
awful lot of them and you have to do
much more technology to that but it
seems that North America has cracked up
and people very confident that certainly
North America in a guess supplied amount
is more or less self-balancing or even
can start exporting LNG the second point
is how how success was and confidential
gas in the rest of the world and I would
say that's anyone's guess maybe we are
geologically but still a lot of wells
have to be drilled people have to have
confidence that actually they can't find
sweet spots there's a lot of societal
debate still and therefore our new
scenarios which are going to publish in
beginning next year
one of the critical insurgents as we
call these scenarios is is that gas
there or isn't that gas there but really
because that's almost bipolar if it's
there you have an enormous opportunity
to change your energy system but if it's
there it'll be very regional so key
uncertainty still any more questions out
there oh yes quite a lot of hands I'll
take a couple of together I'd like to
take gentlemen the second row and the
lady of the yellow top jacket three
thank you yes I'm Paul Eakins from
University College London Institute of
sustainable resources thank you for your
talk also UK energy Research Center two
very quick questions based on statements
that were made the first is by the chair
that gas was a relatively low option
compared with coal well that of course
is true in those countries where it
would substitute for coal but the UK is
not one of those and it is often
presented as a substitute for coal in
the UK but we won't have coal in the UK
to any extent beyond 2020 and the second
which you said when which is that it
will deal with intermittency
it will indeed and will be crucial to
deal with intermittency but only at very
low levels of use and at the moment the
market would not subsidize or the market
would not bear investment in
power stations in that very low level of
use so my questions to you are is the
extensive use of unabated gas compatible
with the UK's carbon reduction targets
in 2050 and if not as I suspect should
we wait for any new - for gas until the
technical and commercial feasibility of
gas CCS has been proved
hold that thought just a second while we
take the lady's question in the one to
fifth row in the yellow jacket thank you
I'm Charlotte Morton from the anaerobic
digestion and buying gas Association
which potentially reveals my question it
was a very interesting presentation and
I agree with a lot of the issues just
surprised that in talking about gas
there has been no mention of renewable
gas which therefore helps address the
CEO tuitions them issues by gas can
generate about 10% of the UK's domestic
gas demand so why wouldn't we be looking
at it and it can be scaled up very fast
and Rea cheaply so I agree with that
also the Netherlands are looking at
biogas we have a lot of animals waste
etc we can use the that is estimated can
be 8% of the total gas the mountain in
certain sectors so it's significant and
it's being developed and actually you
can see it actually be developed not
because of code from policy big but
because of farmers and then the
greenhouse growers actually see it as a
good cost effective way to reduce the
energy bills so it's actually it's going
on another element actually in this
greenhouse gas business and agriculture
is such geothermal warmth right might
actually directly take us from the
ground or actually use solar bonus so
this integrated loop systems in certain
areas is really taking off and then I
come back to Paul's point as yes biogas
is very important or commercial biomass
if it's in our terms and we assume that
there will be quite a significant amount
of biogas available which goes into gas
fired power stations and also in our
outlook we assume that CCS is going to
be developed on all new power stations
post-2020 in Europe honestly otherwise
you don't go there now having said that
I mean said early gainsay with replaces
a little bit of coal left in in the UK
plus the downturn and economic activity
plus the efficiency drive which supposed
to happen probably the UK could have
something like I said 15 to 20 percent
carbon reduction compared to 1990 by in
2020 but thereafter becomes very
difficult and then it becomes sure what
kind of posts do you take if it is
unabated then you won't get stuck to
that that you can't go any further so
you must have CCS and that's what we
assume in our modelling but then we
still got stuck around 45 at best 45
percent by 2050 and if it's the kind of
business as usual scenario so you don't
have much policy support for CCS you
probably will stick to about you go down
you go back up to only 15% abatement so
yes without guests without CCS in long
term is not the the solution for a lower
carbon system it has to come combined
and that's why our company is actually
willing to invest a lot in that
technology and demonstrate it can be
done commercially and cost-effectively
thank you very much did you want to
continue if you feel that you've covered
it but if there's anything else you want
to say very briefly well just yes well
in that case you are retired oh thank
you got got very
- I was sort of puzzling about the way
to hit your emissions target being
possibly to stay in recession forever
but maybe let's not put that once the
politicians but we obviously know we're
moving into a key battleground now which
is the environment it's it's already
come up and the question of where the
gas will warm us up or help us cool down
and particularly whether the
gasification of electricity is part of
the solution already part of the problem
for greenhouse emissions joining us now
professor Mike Stevenson who is head of
science and energy at the British
Geological Survey and Mike you're ten
minutes begins now thank you very much
and as you might expect I'm going to
give you a geological perspective on
this and I will follow in some of the
things that been said about CCS I've got
a lot to say so I'll try and say it
without confusing you this photograph
here you're probably thinking why have I
shown you a picture of a sort of
suburban street it happens to be in
Blackpool which is quite interesting for
this discussion because what it shows is
a big crack that goes just underneath my
name there and that crack was very
famous in Blackpool for a short time
because it purportedly appeared after an
earthquake which was related to fracking
rather nearby that it's fracking for
shale gas hydraulic fracturing and
people said that the frack had appeared
the crack had appeared in the bridge and
people also said that motorbikes had
fallen over them that and that traffic
lights stopped working and things like
that
and a lot of people said yes the crack
appeared and it was for caused by the
fracking now the bgs detected this
earthquake and our view was there's no
way that the energy of the earthquake
could have caused that crack then and in
fact if you read the article which was
attached to this photograph if you got
knocked down to the bottom it said an
old black poor man said in fact that
crack has been there since 1972 so but
this this characterizes the argument of
shale gas that there's an awful lot of
stuff going on which you can't tell is
true or false and this it's rather got
worse unfortunately this is a game black
ball and black pool and net there are
people saying on websites that black
pool
the Costa Blackwell is at risk of
sinking below sea level and our sea sea
defenses will have to be rebuilt
essentially there is no foundation
whatsoever to this it simply won't
happen it's ridiculous
and unfortunately this sort of debate is
getting wider and wider and the public
are getting fired up with things which
are not not true which are
scientifically without foundation so
this is going to be a little bit of the
spirit of my talk which is the
importance of a proper debate a reasoned
and a mature debate so that we can make
good policy so that we can make good
decisions because at the moment I don't
think we can so do a bit of science I'm
sorry to show you a graph so early but
this is a famous graph from Pacolet and
tsoukalos science papers in 2004 many of
you would have seen this it's a very
clever paper some people don't like it
now but at the time it was very good
because what they did was they took the
business-as-usual
which is the ruinous high co2 emissions
rate which might end us up with a very
high temperature rise and they also drew
a graph of the 500 parts per million
stabilization level so in other words a
level of how emissions might increase in
the future and how they might be
stabilized to develop only a 500 parts
per million which would be safe and then
they divided that triangle up which they
called the stabilisation triangle into a
series of wedges which they called
stabilisation wedges and these wedges
are a bit like a scientific unit of
climate abatement if you like and what
you would do is you take one off and if
you do that then your problem gets less
if you take two off and you're getting
nearer to your to your ideal level so
what is a wedge well a wedge would be
doubling global nuclear power a wedge
would be converting 2 billion cars from
30 miles per gallon to 60 miles per
gallon so 2 billion smart cars instead
of 2 billion Lamborghinis and another
one is CCS on 800 power stations
and another one is gas and you've got to
give them credit for this because they
recognized the value of gas in 2004 they
said if you replace a substantial number
of gas power stations or a coal power
stations with gas power stations in fact
1500 gigawatts worth of 50% efficient
coal power stations you'll get a wench
so that also in 2004 along came shale
gas in the United States and this
picture from nature nicely shows it you
can see about 2004 2005 that's when
fracking really took off and horizontal
drilling and look where shale gas might
be in the future in 2035 it might be
producing half of America's domestic gas
an extraordinary extraordin approach
action what does the industry think
about this well this nice appearance of
shale gas the the tantalizing
possibility of a wedge being offered by
it well this is from Malcom britta'd
shale who I spoke alongside at a Royal
Society talk a couple of months ago who
said well displacing Gulf Coal Fired
power and natural gas at the fattest
fastest and cheapest way to reduce co2
in the global power sector he didn't
really go into whether it was with CCS
or not he didn't go into whether it was
a bridge to renewables or a backbone as
a been said so in other words we take
shale gas for a while and then when
renewable czar up to power then we dump
the shale gas but it wasn't quite clear
so it's not quite sure clear you know
where we are on that
of course carbon capture story is
incredibly important because without it
it's going to be very difficult to use
fossil fuels at all so let's look at
some figures now lamentably there are
very few figures about whether shale gas
or natural gas is truly more green than
other kinds of gas or other kinds of
energy the modeling and the work studies
haven't been done in sufficient detail
there is something that was published by
the European Commission about a month
ago which was about shale gas in
relation to other energy types and what
they said was in Poland
if you Chapin Poland is extremely
dependent it's extremely dependent for
its electricity on coal something like
90% of its electricity is generated from
coal if Poland converted overnight to
shale gas power stations which you
probably would like to do it would cut
its emissions by 41 to 49 percent which
is a very large cut so Poland would
immediately become a lot greener but
what about the world well essentially if
we take the high gas scenario of the IEA
from the golden rules of owners for a
golden age of gas and it doesn't add up
because they say that you did the high
gas use scenario you'd get three point
five degrees C percent warming which is
highly dangerous but of course gas could
be part of a wage it doesn't have to be
a cos of wedgies it could be one wedge
but there is a problem and this is where
I'm going to make my pitch to you
there's a real problem with these wedges
I said that there are several wedges
that have been described one shale gas
to nuclear double gloopy double global
nuclear power three 800 CCS operations
on 800 power stations unfortunately the
public won't have it because all those
three things nuclear shale gas and CCS
all of them have the same problem the
same lack of belief amongst the public
and that might feed through to policy
makers and investors as well they worry
about it the earth is scary people are
frightened of earthquakes
look at this a Somerset expert reckons
that if you do shale gas in the men dips
it will turn into a volcano and people
believe it
you know they people believe it and and
this is the quality of the debate that's
out there you know I'm not saying that
shale gas is the answer I'm not saying
that CCS is I'm not saying that double
global nuclear power either is and but
it's it's a problem because if you you
want to do these things they're all
geological and the public you know have
many many questions about the
feasibility and the safety of it so what
am i arguing for well yes
naively I'm arguing that science needs
to take a stronger role in this
particularly independence of science to
assess the risk and to do it publicly
and transparently and openly and to talk
about what snow race things we don't
have to worry about like volcanoes and
Blackpool disappearing under the the
Irish Sea high-risk things and there are
high risks things there are things that
we should worry about you know like meat
and methane getting into water supplies
for example these are things we should
think about and but the trouble is the
debate is revealing over to these
ridiculous things and we get distracted
and you know what matters is the
difference between these two things if
we did that we might get a better
quality debate we might have to get
better policy as well Thanks let's have
some questions do we have some questions
here I've got a lady at the front
already keen to get in thanks thanks
very much Mike Jenny banks from WWF UK I
was actually going to ask a question
quite similar to professor professor
Ekans point about not building any more
coal but in light of the fact that's
already been asked just just a point
really about global fossil fuel reserves
if you look at global conventional known
reserves about 80 percent of them can't
actually be be effectively burnt or used
if we want to stay within 2 degrees of
warming and that's without looking at
unconventionals
and then if you look at the u.s. the
claim is that that emissions have fallen
because of shale gas and that that might
be the case but actually the coal is is
production is the same it's just going
elsewhere so isn't this actually about
keeping the stuff in the ground keeping
the stuff in the ground well that I
think all I'm saying is that you know
I'm not advocating any of these things
I'm simply saying that if you want to do
them you're going to have to communicate
the science better and the risks you
know to the public better otherwise
we're not going to have these wedges and
I'm not advocating shale gas or nuclear
or anything else and the public public
service I don't
I'm simply here to explain what I think
is that is the issue and the main issue
is if you want to have you know fossil
fuels or nuclear you know or or shale
gas well you're going to have to be able
to address these issues otherwise it's
not going to happen but it does sound
odd for you to say yeah of course public
servant it if you want any of them I
mean you you must have a view on some
sort of preference or some sort of risk
that attaches to one and not to another
yeah I mean there are as I said there
are risks for example to do with
earthquakes in fracking in in shale gas
and you know and there are there is
science that we can do to mitigate those
risks there are there's science that we
can do that to develop a procedure
whereby a company that like frack can
can be slowed down there could be a
traffic light system whereby if they get
to an earthquake of a certain size that
can be told to stop fracking but that's
the appliance of science if you like to
use a term and advertising term you know
that that shows how you can do this but
you have to do the work in other words
in order to you know distinguish low
risk from high risk I'll try and take so
we might take these two together if you
do hello Robert page I'm studying
geology at Imperial and possibly if
people like the WWF Greenpeace the BBC
and the Guardian didn't fill the
public's imagination with such scare
mongering there might be a chance for
the proper science to have an
independent and look and actually
possibly if we stop bashing the energy
companies can the whole time might be
discovered that the wind farms they
dream of don't actually solve any energy
problems and possibly don't help our co2
either so you obsessed with bringing
down co2 but maybe the way to do that is
through gas and then we both have an
energy supply which we can rely on and
we help the environment BB Seto yes sir
at the front
thank you Tony cousin price from open
democracy and intelligence squared I'm
interested to know Mike whether you
think that there's a is there a science
to the perception of risk I'm quite
struck by the fact that in the u.s.
somehow other it seems as if these
perceptions of risk have gone a
different way might that be linked to
different interests that people have I
mean after all in the u.s. if you own a
piece of land then you own the geology
underneath it because does the
perception of risk depend on our
institutions in that sort of way yeah of
course and you hits on it quite rightly
that you know in the United States if
you have shale gas into your farm or
your house then you stand to gain from
it directly in Britain you don't so that
changes the argument quite a bit and
there is an extremely well developed
science of risk and you can be sure that
we're working on this and you know
British regulators take on the science
of risk in a very thorough fully and
very rigorously and but you know we've
seen this already we know that we have
amongst the best and tightest
regulations for offshore gas offshore
oil and gas in the world and you know
generally the North Sea's been extremely
successful in doing that in regulating
properly and making sure it's safe with
a few unfortunate you know exceptions
but the people of blackbook don't don't
take that you know they don't want that
and and again I'm not I don't want to be
seen as somebody who's pushing fossil
fuels at all I'm saying that you know if
you want to have them then the science
has to be properly community and
communicated and just going to the
gentleman's comment I don't agree with
what you're saying about Greenpeace and
you know World Wildlife Fund because
these are all people you contribute to
the debate and you make us think you
know beyond you know if we are a fossil
fuel company whatever you think beyond
that and it's important to have all
those stakeholders in the argument and
in the discussion so and they often put
over the science very well
I mean occasionally you know it might be
over overwrought and that this stuff
about you know mendax volcanoes isn't
coming from
well Wildlife Fund or Greenpeace so
shall we move on to the next part of
course all of this depends on and takes
place in the context of the geopolitical
situation and the question of whether
energy independence will give us a
greater security and also what that sort
of security would look like
correspondent in Moscow in the early to
mid 90s and this was a period in which
it was seen as a sort of no-brainer that
this was the way things were going to go
followed by a period of perhaps alarm
that this was not going to be the case
and I think that we're therefore very
good time to hear from our next speaker
which is dr. shamil en aquella who is
research fellow at the Oxford Institute
story of energy studies and his
forthcoming book is the battle for
Russian oil corporations regions and the
state you have 10 minutes Emil to sort
all that out yes it's a fascinating
story I think geopolitics because it's
often misunderstood that's why it's even
more fascinating for people I think that
time I'll start first by talking about
the early 2000s when we were in a
situation of high oil prices and long
term contracts between a gas prompt and
its customers in Europe and long term
contracts which were linked to oil
prices and at the time Europe was I
think a little bit concerned that it
needs to rely on Russia to balance its
energy demand and I was a drive at the
European Union level for this
diversification of supply and talks
about new supplies new supply sources
particularly from the Caspian and
Central Asia
how does he how does Russia use its
position
at that particular time the position of
high oil prices the position of far
really great influence in terms of gas
supplies so first it offers sweet deals
on gas in exchange for controller
transit pipelines in Ukraine Belarus and
Moldova and also for some downstream
assets or to countries which appear to
be friendly but then there's also uses
is control over transit routes from
Central Asia to make market access hard
for Central Asian producers at the same
time it's thus promoting expensive
transit avoidance pipelines having
failed to somewhat reach a mutually
acceptable agreement with transit
countries it started building expensive
pipelines which bypass those transit
countries no stream
gas through that pipeline has already is
already running and South Stream to
avoid transit through those countries so
what happens subsequently is that
obviously because you all know the shale
gas revolution in the United States a
great excitement great excitement about
the new gas abundance and also the
result of change of X with markets for
liquefied natural gas which was supposed
to go to the United States and now is
going to Europe and also this affects
the traditional price formula that
Gazprom was using and its deals with
Europe and there is a talk about
delinking all prices so gas prices from
oil crisis and bias 6 price
renegotiation and Gazprom starts losing
its market share in Europe because of
this new sources of gas at the same time
one interesting development of this
period is that Russia also ends its
China ends its monopoly and
to russia's monopoly in central asia by
constructing Turkmenistan pipeline from
turkmenistan by Uzbekistan and
Kazakhstan to China which is done there
and and at the same time Gazprom comes
under increased domestic pressure from
politically connected independent gas
producers to allow access to its expert
its expert monopoly and also to
reconsider the price the price system
that just prom is using in his days with
zero one interesting aspect of this all
is the cheap and plentiful gas in the
United States and how it's going to play
or be played by both in the United
States both domestically but also
internationally if the gas is used
domesticated could potentially hurt
European manufacturing and chemical
industries because of the United States
will have competitive advantage it could
also displace oil so North American oil
could flower start flowing to
international markets and become more
volumes will be available and as a
result we'll see we may see massive the
reduction of us dependence on the Middle
East and the question will be whether
the United States will disengaged
militarily and then diplomatically
from that region and agreed to be
replaced with with China China as you
can see from this slide is a premium
market for LNG which is no longer needed
in the United States China role in
Central Asia has also increased because
of pipeline projects and also because
Russia is the declining power there and
in a way Chinese becoming the the very
important player in terms of creating a
new energy Silk Road from Iran
to the forest and promoting potentially
promoting a greater stability in the
region okay but what will Russia will do
what what Russia is likely to do in this
in this situation
Russia's lucky to choose gas volumes of
a prices because Gazprom is at the
moment is under a lot of pressure from
independent gas producers whose gas
production is actually lower
domestically it caused them it's not
doesn't cause them as much to produce
gas but also because cat acts
contribution of Russian gas sector is
only three to five percent when it comes
to the Russian budget what it means that
low gas prices will change the you
energy mix in favor of gas it will
promote economic recovery in Europe and
demand as well but at the same time it
will undermine renewables and LNG at the
same time we know the interesting aspect
about those transit avoidance but one
which I mentioned early is that Russia
backed pipelines north stream in South
Stream could potentially transport mule
increased Russian volumes they now make
sense that not makes sense
so those pipelines will be used for that
purpose and the final final slide and
some final points okay does gas help or
hinder making the world a safer place
obviously the increased availability of
supplies and increase the rest of
sources is a very important factor and
because gas producers are being becoming
more responsible may being being more
responsible by new this new competition
and producer consumer relations as a
result a mutual dependence will create
greater stability at the same time some
transnational pipelines such as
Turkmenistan Afghanistan Pakistan India
pipeline could promote as well
integration and stability in those
regions but one final point is that the
battles will continue but it would be
battles based on based around markets
routes regulation techno
a competitive advantage in prices and
environment and domestic politics will
play the key role in that particularly
in the United States and Russia thank
you thank you very much Camille's
minutes is about as long as a st.
Petersburg night in the summer but we
have one hand up at the front here and I
think yes I might take a few questions
together but we could take the lady at
the front first and then this gentleman
here and I can see you all as well
hi I'm catching cabarrus from the Center
for European reform I'm gonna give you
another two minutes on your last point
where the unconventional gas will have a
stabilizing or destabilizing impact on
the International political environment
on the one hand you could of course
argue that if a country such as Poland
has or even Ukraine has significant
unconventional gas fines they will
Russia will no longer be able to place
shenanigans with its energy policy in
its neighborhood so the European scene
looks more stable on the other hand I'm
wondering if nations feel independent
will they start making stupid mistakes
will they will they especially smaller
countries where they start behaving in a
way that is actually destabilizing and
you could even draw that point to China
isn't a bit of energy interdependence in
the world quite a good thing because P
countries need to be nice to each other
if they depend on each other very nice
question thank you can I just have the
hind please an Alex Ferguson from the
CBI I'm interested to hear what you
think or how likely and some global
price convergence is over the medium
term in the gas markets and also how do
you think US domestic politics will
affect and the ability to export LNG
from the US do you think will there be a
a are we moving towards a global gas
price conversions
and if so to what extent yes please take
those two first did we agree mr. beacon
so nice if you yeah the first argument
that I think taking on curtains because
last point about when countries become
independent I think this is something
that Russian politicians has all been
complaining about saying that all this
is the world was a block mentality those
people hate us and they're actually
creating more problems in a relationship
with Europe because they became
independent and they're trying to play
their own political games and I think
that them a lot of that will depend on
whether they will be actually shale gas
development in the foreseeable future in
those countries that you mentioned
because I think that Russians really
have the capacity to act quite quickly
and as I said earlier there is a lot of
pressure now particularly from companies
such as Nova Tech but also from the
Russian oil coal companies particularly
Rosneft - which is moving into gas
business very actively very actively and
could potentially displace gas prone to
a certain degree within Russia and also
externally so I don't know I think that
it's often difficult to make predictions
your question is it related to 10 years
20 years 30 years 40 years but when we
look at this another important aspect to
remember about all these forecasts what
we're talking about if you look at the
the latest they're talking about 2035
2040 so by looking about you know 20-30
years ahead look at what we're now in
year 1920 20-30 years ahead what has
happened in the world so I think this is
this is an important point that the
world is changing at a very fast pace
and I think that a lot of this a lot of
this forecasts and predictions are just
just a guide for us
- no base our decisions used to base our
decisions move through so you get I'm
basically saying that I think it's I
think it's unlikely that they will play
the disability law simply because I
don't I think it will take them quite a
while to actually reach that competitive
advantage level okay in terms of the I
guess the gas prices and and also us
decisions in America I think it will be
in terms of his your last point your
second question I think it's the years
will probably use balls gas domestically
but also exported so I think there will
be a decision reached which will satisfy
all the interested parties in the United
States when it when it comes to global
prices I would not going to answer this
question what I suggest you do is that
on the first of November by a book which
is a set by Johnson Stern which is
dealing with this very issue which is
the book is about global oil global gas
prices okay it's it looks at the
different markets that's always a good
time to move on I'd like to just take
one more brief question at the back
there Allen Riley City University I
think my questions are simply first of
all in relation to the Russian gas
supply the International Energy Agency
last year in the World Energy Outlook
was talking about the Russian gas market
having to replace ninety percent
production by 2035 so 635 billion cubic
meters replace something in the order of
magnitude in terms of investment is 730
billion dollars in 2010 dollars and one
of the questions is can Russia actually
supply that gas especially given its
kind of high nor strategy is that
cheaper gas available actually should
Russia go with shale gas which might be
cheaper itself and the other kind of
bigger question which affects gas prom
and in fact all the gas suppliers
this one of the questions which is not
debated it's not so much the impact of
cheap LNG being dumped in Europe or in
Asia but the effect of the shutting off
of the aapko markets in the United
States because of cheap gas and the coal
being dumped in Europe in other parts of
the world and the danger is is if you
get start getting a lot of shale gas
developed in the rest of the world they
will look for markets to dump the coal
and ironically rather than Europe
leading the world into renewables the
actual future for Europe may well be as
the dumping ground for coal and this
will affect principally the European gas
suppliers like gasp oh I think that's my
mic so my point there's the coal the
issue for guess probing parties about
its gas and its ability to actually
deliver the investment in an area of
high corruption and blow investor
protection another side I think I
partially answered your question when I
said when I talked about the role of
independent gas producers and I talked
about the role of Rosneft one of the
reasons for the current re-emergence of
Rosneft so to speak is that Rosneft
potentially together with international
companies could as I said this place
gets from through so I think just
focusing on gas from is not it's not
really it's not really entirely accurate
I think you should look at when we're
talking about this these issues we need
to look at what the independent
producers can do and can deliver and
again which volumes were talking about
how much how much you know for Russia at
the moment I think the key dilemma is to
retain its role in in European markets
potentially maybe increase it slightly
I'm really gonna bring you to a close
but did you take the coal point
seriously as a sort of serious or
unforeseen consequences that gentleman
suggested not really no I think it's
but you too can saw that one out
afterwards it thank you very much indeed
Samir thank you right well now we're
going to bring it home and back to the
UK for the last the final part so do
stick with us a little the last part of
the debate and I'm going to welcome to
the stage with me dr. Pierre Noel who is
senior research associate and director
of energy policy forum at the University
of Cambridge specializing in oil and gas
markets and Industry and David Howe Lord
Howe was an advisor to the Foreign
Secretary on energy security and a
former Minister of State at the Foreign
Office with responsibility for
international energy issues we'd like to
try and draw together a bit of what
we've heard tonight before the final
round of questions
David Lord Howe from what you heard
tonight do you see a major shift in the
role of gas and the questions about gas
I think a lot of it has happened already
and what the major shift has happened in
America the entire world's gas our
energy mix is being altered while we're
sitting here all sorts of countries
particularly either side of Africa which
are very very concerned with Tanzania
Mozambique Kenya and the other side
Sierra Leone Ghana and Nigeria itself
are all seeing fantastically changed
prospects now as they turns out that
they have got commercially recoverable
shale gas and shale oil tight oil as
well offshore and onshore which is going
to transform their prospects and they're
probably and their politics as well so
it was a huge change going on now and
the question for the politicians and the
policymakers is how this is managed in a
sensible way consistent with what is
generally agreed in all parties in and
in government in this country that we
must move towards the low carbon green
age that we must do it in a sensible way
that we mustn't let the politics screw
up the ambitions and the ID
that is the really tricky area this is
almost entirely to do this this debate
with communication with people and
carrying democratic political societies
in a way that will make the aims of
low-carbon consistent with economic
recovery now and the reasonable a
reasonable carrying of burdens but not
an unreasonable so that's where we are
not what questions did the debate
throughout for you to movies or
observations about the concerns well you
know I think there's a bit of a reality
check to be done currently in Europe all
over Europe gas is displaced gas
consumption is going down everywhere in
all sectors of the economy if we want
more gas to be consumed we can I mean
there's plenty of it on the market but
in Europe gas is squeezed between
renewables that are very heavily
subsidized on the one hand and coal
which is a absurdly cheap on the other
hand we have so you know and and getting
squeezed between the two so one way out
which would be sensible in terms of of
of climate change is to have a carbon
price that's a bit more a bit more
reasonable which by Newbery going to be
a bit higher I mean I which would at the
very least restore the competitiveness
of gas against coal but the way we
subsidize renewables actually depresses
the carbon price in Europe so we have a
set of completely inconsistent policies
that give us the worst of all world
which is the high cost of renewables and
the high emissions of coal occasionally
expressed some frustration with it with
the green agenda they put it rather
politely saying all parties you know
should work towards carrying a
reasonably burdened
as you have suggested that this burden
may be actually rather unreasonable well
what I'm really saying is Esther's done
something paradoxical is that the green
agenda if pressed incompetently in
political terms with the wrong
compelling messages imposed on people in
the wrong ways will actually delay the
Green Revolution B and we just had a
perfect example here but people are
saying oh we must be very careful about
gas expansion and we've done to share
gas America's fine but we don't want to
see too much encouragement here what is
the net effect of that the net effect is
that American coal is pouring into
Europe we're burning more coal here in
this country
Europe's cold as a whole is increasing
the actual on Germans are planning new
coal-fired stir stations with and co2
while informing falling to America to
the 2020 year level lowest level and
form 14% in the last two years and the
per capita emissions has fallen
dramatically so it's not just a
recession issue quite a two year horizon
in a time of local low US growth can I
call you on that well you can call me
but the 57 million extra people in
America in the last 20 years and yet the
carbon co2 emissions of now 20 percent
are and they are very low now compared
to anyway that's so the here's the
zealotry of overeager I'm as green as
the next I want to see a low-carbon high
efficiency low intensity density economy
but if you press this too far get the
politics wrong what do you do you create
more pure property which is what we're
happening now with very high gas prices
or where we haven't thought of it would
get worse with high if they're
maintained you apparently generate far
from less EO to generate more you damage
competitiveness of Industry you
obviously weaken the growth of jobs and
delay the recovery this seems a very
expensive advance a very expensive
procedure in order to rush through too
fast the Green Revolution it's a
question of pace and communication
that's what it is it's pace
communication
and politics no just coming on that if
you'd like to and what was the question
again
well the question is I suppose one do
you see it the same way that David sees
it or indeed if you want to outline
something of your your own excessive
solutions please do that you know I
think there's a what's happening in the
UK is very interesting because you have
a situation that's politically very
difficult for for for the government it
would be as difficult if it was the
Labour Party running the country it's
not a question of parties it's a
question of the country has committed to
some targets that yes what are very
expensive to reach and politicians have
spent the better part of the past decade
telling people don't worry it's going to
be very cheap we're going to go green
and we're going to save money at the
same time to me to be great
and now the invoices are starting to to
come and and it's suddenly the very
beginning we've barely scratched the
surface so I have basically two messages
the first one is whatever we do on
climate change we have to do it cost
effectively we have to start with the
cheapest carbon emission reductions that
we can get currently we're starting with
the most expensive works offshore winds
is a typical example solar panels is
another to become India what the cost of
them is falling quite quickly we have to
be honest but seem very very hard that's
the first message do it good do it cost
effectively the the only way that I know
how to do that is simply to tax carbon
right at the highest level that the
political process will will allow which
we may not be very very high but
hopefully will be higher than what we
currently have the second message is
let's be very honest about the long term
objectives if we don't have a meaningful
global agreement that will map a way to
share the burden of addressing this
global problem there will not be any
low-carbon system in any country there
will be a lower carbon that's that
compared to what we have because we
won't get a global agreed legally
binding system we've tried that the
Chinese are not going to touch that the
Russians are not gonna touch it the
Americans are not going to touch it or
amis we trade with oldest people that is
the fantasy world but we will get lower
carbon on a substantial scale America is
happy is enjoying it now because at
least partly of the shale gas revolution
will switch from coal to gas China is
actually although their emissions are
very very high and they were great a
mess up they are applying all kinds of
new energy technologies they're
brilliant at solar reducing the cost of
solar so it may come within reach right
so this is really this is the talk about
global targets you see is the wrong
approach I'm afraid I think the right
approach is technology we have to apply
the technologies to get the cost of CCS
down to get the so long way way down it
can go from can be reduced by nine
tenths in over the next few years if we
really concentrate on technology and
government support for the technology
for green it for green technologies we
will make progress if we go on about
targets and taxes we work will just get
political reaction and will go backwards
as we are doing now we actually I
entirely agree that spending money on
R&D is is key to any any serious energy
and climate policy R&D spending on
energy has gone down 80% in 30 years so
you know it just gives you a bit of a
really that's a geisha girl China and
green energy win for China and green
energy is is my favorite or I've got a
spreadsheet in my computer where I track
year after year the percentage of the
growth in Chinese energy
energy consumption that's covered by
coal it used to be 98 percent and now
it's 78 percent you know and it's going
down very slowly so you know yes I mean
they they they sent that you know they
they manufacture solar panels but they
sent to to Germany because the German
consumers is apparently very very
willing to to pay to transfer subsidies
to China this will stop before before we
start doing it let's bring this back to
shell girls mr. little telling the
Chinese Energy Minister told me the
other day in Brussels that China had a
five-year plan for shale gas that they
had more shale gas in America if they
could get to it he admitted the
geological problems which I some other
Chairman said that his Chinese were
saying some of these shale gas deposits
are under cities a little or flaws so so
but they have got if they move that way
to show gas they will achieve more in
terms of reducing the growth of carbon
emissions than anything else than all
these other fancy Chloe I read you
reducing the grossing the growth yes but
he's not going to give you 450 ppm I
would love to bring anyone in who just
feels that they've got a if you could
make the short pointed questions would
be very appreciated the gentleman in the
blue shirt and then oh gosh so many
hands there lady in the black top and
we'll see how far we get do we have a
microphone anyone who puts a hand up and
gets a microphone go first as far as I'm
concerned going to be the lady in the
black top and if you could keep them
really short and also you're thank you
very much my name is Natasha moon yeh
and I work in the investment side and
I'm curious on your views about the
taxation of carbon the the current
system of carbon permits is really
dysfunctional cost very little it's
about seven eight years of time and yet
if that were to go up our energy bill
would go up to it because it's clearly
passed on to the consumers so it really
creates a conundrum I'm not sure what's
best in terms of carbon reduction and
what's best
the consumers and the politicians who we
vote for will take it a questionnaire
yes thank you
any Peyser from the global warming
policy foundation I don't know whether
you've seen the recent debate between
President Obama and Roma but basically
they were vying who would get more oil
and coal and gas out of the ground
climate change didn't feature but they
they try to portray themselves as people
who would even get more out of the
ground so I think we need a little bit
of a reality check
climate change is debt internationally
even in Europe countries are rolling
back the policies and it's obvious that
the countries in the next 20-30 years
that have the cheapest form of energy
will be the successful countries and the
countries where the most expensive form
of energies will go down the drain
that's the reality and I wonder whether
the penny is beginning to drop in this
country
yes but the cheapest form of energy will
come from those with the cleverest
technology and the greatest efficient
use of energy that that's that's where
it's come back to the technology point I
mean I didn't practically grieve any
that the climate debate is dead there
are a lot of people who are rightly
concerned that we could be heading for a
great climate violence of an increasing
kind and leading a vast suffering to
numbers of people so that is not there
there was the exchange tonight between
Mitt Romney and Barack Obama was quite
amusing because Mitt Romney said to back
you're not an oil man and Barack Obama
said well you're not a gas man so it's
it's a question of technology I'm the
the the fear I have is that the over
zealotry the people saying no let's push
up the prices let's have carbon permits
so poised that carbon becomes crippling
ly expensive and a disincentive to all
gas and everything
those who say never mind about the
consumers never mind
fuel poverty never mind about industry
let's pile on the costs so that we get a
minimum subsidy for renewables those
people are going to wreck the whole
program frankly they're going to destroy
it the green program could you possibly
take on a bit of the first question on
yes well you know the problem we have is
that the damage we caused to the global
environment is not reflected in the
price of the energy we consume right
that's the most basic definition of the
problem which we have if you bring even
partly the the cost the what we call the
external cost of your facility or
consumption into the price of energy you
raised you know your price is a bit
higher or much higher if you do it if
you do it meaningfully there's no way
around that
yes addressing climate change is all
about changing the relative prices of
energy to make the carbon intensive ones
relatively more expensive and the carbon
less intensive one relatively less
expensive it's all about what the public
will believe and what they will take in
the way of messages public can't believe
whatever they want the ton of co2 ton of
corn oxygen a democracy it actually
matters well well they did that wasn't
wasn't the point that we heard err it
was Mike Mike Stevens who pointed out
that it was a real problem what the
public believed well and and what he
committed and the power of those who
have got authority on the elegance in
order to convey the right message the
saving the world message of our always
absolutely hopeless it is not convincing
anybody at all
you don't want you probably would not be
malleable so let's just try a couple of
really really questions towards the end
and then you gentlemen could sum up
there was some hands at the back hope
they did yes there's a gentleman here
yes please I want you to just come back
to sorry Alan Riley City University I
was almost appear about his the issue
about China I mean I talked to the
Chinese and when they talk about the
scale
of the the resource base in China of
shale gas there they say yes there are
difficulties but the potential in terms
of their own energy security the
potential in terms of reducing not just
the co2 issues but the general terrible
levels of pollution from coal in Chinese
city the incentives are so correct
that's you know the idea of having the
plan which is I think six and a half
billion cubic meters by 2015 100 billion
cubic meters by 2020 and then looking at
something to six to eight hundred
billion cubic meters but by 2030 they
see that as potentially achievable now
if they do do that surely you are
talking about something which is a real
blunting of climate change
because at the end of the day right
there the sharp end of co2 emissions
okay so let's have this one we haven't
heard from before the gentleman in the
middle with the glasses could you
possibly get the mic in here please in
the middle thanks my name's Archie
Fraser I'm an alternative energy analyst
in the city the speakers have made a
couple of points about the fall in the
cost of solar energy and the potential
future for but I wonder if they're
really aware of the scale of what has
happened in solar energy I just like to
chuck three facts at them firstly the
cost of a solar module has fallen 80% in
the last four years from about three
euros a watt to about sixty cents that's
just a question of fact
secondly the amount that you can be paid
in Germany for a rooftop system under
the feed-in tariff is now well below
what you actually pay for retail
electricity so if you choose to buy
electricity you will pay about ten
percent more than the government will
pay you for your rooftop system which
shows pretty clearly that the system is
competitive but below the level of
retail cost and thirdly I'd just like to
point out that several gigawatts of
ground mounted solar systems are
currently in development in Spain
developers are putting in tens hundreds
of millions of cost in developing
several gigawatts of projects which are
not explained
did or intended to receive any subsidy
at all right so we've got one shiny
question hang on your solar
three-pointer
no more three-pointers but if anyone's
got one really let's go on this lady up
here who's got a hand nice and high and
looks like she's got a very brief
pointed question my name is Nicola park
i'm i working industrial gas rather than
the natural gas and energy field but
i've also a stem ambassador and we talk
a lot about technology is going to be
the source i've been to a school today
and lots of these kids are not
interested in in stem subjects but we
need them to come forward in order to
bring these technology so that we can
solve this problem what do you think we
should be doing about that so it was
really about getting it was your
question was how to get interest across
in the new technologies yeah she was an
interesting question because it's come
through tonight a bit of frustration
that we don't win over public support
and public opinion isn't oh I think I
think there's an enormous where we
getting at the ends and know what amount
to be done in schools about the
excitement and possibilities of the new
technology but they've got to get the
cost down what is what is naughty in the
political world is pretending as I think
someone said earlier in the debate that
we can get to this renewable green
low-carbon world with less problems of a
Middle East oil less problems of digging
up the earth and so on and can do it in
a way that is all very easy and won't
cost a lot of suffering and difficulty
it can be done but it's got to be done
very slowly and carefully and it is the
misleading
idea that we can jump to the low-carbon
economy without pain we have said that I
think you should move on and talk just
briefly give a reply on solar if you
could I can't give you a very actually
what you're saying is is largely correct
and indeed I alluded to it earlier
except I think it's a night it's fallen
by nine times not eight times in the
last five years the solar prospects are
great the Chinese have got way ahead in
the technology it is a very big hope for
all the villages in desert and poorer
areas around the world
a billion and a quarter people have gone
electricity at all can when they get on
the huge grids
very difficult and much cheaper and
possibly a morgues
we're Israeli efficient and low-cost
PVCs for low-cost solar development it's
full of potential it's very exciting but
it all comes down to cost and the
Chinese are leading the way on that and
well Don them
let's at Piron know well the cost of
solar is going down I mean fantastic
it's it's I mean like I mean again if we
if the cost of play of clean heat and
electricity doesn't fall down
dramatically we're not going to solve
this problem right because we're never
going to impose on ourselves the types
of carbon prices we would need to
address it meaningfully right so the
cost of solar has gone down fantastic
the bill has been extremely high for
those who have actually been primed this
market just last year the total amount
of green energy I mean of renewable
energy subsidies in Germany was 17
billion euros a year it's going to be
nearly 20% more than that this year and
Institue it's for 25 years right 17
billion euros a year just to give you a
point of comparison Abu Dhabi bought 60
gigawatts of nuclear power from the
South Koreans for 5.6 billion euros and
is that dispatchable zero carbon power
so the Germans have paid for bringing
them down the cost of solar not by
actually improving the technology at all
just bringing the Chinese Israel and now
they're lasting the rest of us France
the UK to support them in an antitrust
case against China I mean you know
that's right you mentioned Spain okay so
now that the cost has gone down perhaps
that they need less subsidies or maybe
no services at all which is great which
is great I and I agree with you well the
past 10 years the the the the the the
the government in Spain has refused for
the cost of renewables to be reflected
in the tariff
so what they did is they created this
huge debt which guess what they
securitized so they created another new
junk bond which is implicitly granted by
the Germans because it's in the eurozone
well that you can buy if you want to
you're in the city you can buy it we go
wrong give you toys these are all the
problems your class these are all the
problems if you'll go the wrong way
which we've been going in many areas of
attempting to subsidize renewables the
future if we want to get co2 down it's
gotta be step by step it's got a bit
politically practical it's got time and
again it's all about technology
technology technology of course the cost
asked us to go down it's not going down
magically it's good and if you throw
money at it lots of money at ease who
pays for that the cost of technology is
not going to go down like that so we go
you know we we cannot go around the
problem this is a serious policy problem
because it's very expensive Chinese
technology is bringing down the price
and there are many other ways where we
can get the price down I agree needs
government support that's absolutely
right but it's much better spending
money that way than subsidizing useless
wind farms and also finish your point
Amancio need can't have some dinner it
is very heavy German subsidies for solar
that brought the Chinese in and the
prices down it's not magic technology
it's not magic at all but I do hope that
we have generators at least a bit of
lighter as well as rather a lot of heat
particularly at the end of our debate
tonight look thanks to all of our
speakers and of course to intelligence
squared and shell for hosting this event
which I've certainly enjoyed very much
and hope you have we would be very
grateful if you could fill in the
feedback forms which are on your chairs
or probably under your chairs by now if
you got agitated and kicked them out of
the way and thank you all so much for
coming safe journey home
you